the Joe Rogan experience you are doing
something really bonkers right now right
you're attempting to run across the
entire country and to break the record
yeah so this is kind of in its infancy a
bit from the planning stages so I
probably won't happen in the immediate
future but someone you're very familiar
with actually Justin Wren yeah he's got
the fight for their gotten I was
actually on the phone with him last
night and one thing I've kind of been
interested in since I started ultra
running is this route it's a 30 100 mile
route basically it goes from San
Francisco to New York and it's been done
by you know quite a few people with
walking running Pete Cassel Nick he's
got the course record I'd only averages
like 70 miles a day yeah yeah so it's
like it's it's a pretty insane route and
I've always been interested in doing it
and I just haven't really been motivated
I guess to really attempt it or I just
didn't I guess I just really didn't know
when I would do it I just kind of I
would and then um last year one of my
one of my sponsors the f-bomb those nut
butters actually I love those yeah but
my friend RZA and I they believe that
the name should be changed they believe
nut butter has a negative connotation to
heterosexual males who think that it's
sounds like something comes out of your
dick a name change but maybe good well I
guess in their defense there's this
called f-bomb not nut butter right so
right right in gender right it's a
better name yeah yeah stuff I love their
stuff ya know they make a great product
and they had actually proposed a Laster
that I think they just were maybe
spitballing a little bit but they're
like hey would you be ever interested in
doing that like go running you know
doing that cross country route and I was
like yeah I've been actually wanting to
do that at some point I just haven't
gotten around to actually planning it
out how funny is that as a statement
yeah I've been wanting to run thirty-one
hundred miles across the [ __ ]
continent and try to beat the record
which averaged 60 to 70 miles a day god
damn dude how would you prepare for that
uh yeah you know I mean I might be in
super unchartered territory because I've
just haven't done anything like that
before
so it would be
difficult you'd be a lot of thought of
learning on the fly I think really the
big key thing there is you're managing a
lot of stuff with that like you want to
make sure you're sleeping well
throughout that because obviously if
you're not sleeping well it could end
badly for you pretty soon so then I
think you just end up trying to do as
much specific things as you can to
prepare without going overboard so just
a lot of time on feet I mean you can
imagine the pace is gonna be incredibly
slow there's probably gonna be like
walking breaks I'm not gonna be like
you're certainly not gonna running 60 40
per mile pace but my my first thought is
like I'll probably target like a 12 to
14 hour range per day and you whatever I
get out of that 12 to 14 days or hours
is what I get and then that gives me
kind of the flexibility to have like at
least ten hours of buffer to kind of
like prep and sleep and get ready for
the next day do you know Eddie Izzard is
yeah uh-huh are you aware of what he did
well you ran the entire length to the UK
yeah the outside of it with no training
right he's an animal man he really is a
special person really is a special
person I remember only knowing of him as
a comedian and you know had seen him do
a lot of stand-up before and then I
watched his documentary where he's
running I mean how many mile how many
different marathons was it was like 26
27 and 27 days 27 marathons in 27 days
he did wind up taking one day off for
his feet were literally mangled blisters
he'll imagine he wasn't in shape which
is this [ __ ] crazy just sheer
willpower I mean just to do one marathon
when you're not in shape I just can't
imagine the the just a [ __ ] sheer
amount of just will just pure will that
it takes to do something like that and
to just keep pushing left right left
right left right left right even though
everything your head your brain your
feet everything stop stop stop
[ __ ] you left right left right left
right I mean he ran how many thousand
miles was it the entire length of the UK
over the outside too though he did 43
marathons
oh he's in South Africa right 43 and 51
days
first one and then 27 and 27 days was
the second one 43 43 [ __ ] marathons
the article in 2009 Queen Elliot was
celebrating after finishing his 43rd
marathon in 51 days he's really really
interesting guy yeah it's guys you call
he's he's Eddie Izzard but he's a
crossdresser
so he's like it's he comes out as
transgender I think but not really cuz
he likes women and he likes women as a
man he just likes dressing as a woman
he's just a really unique guy but but he
owns it you know I'm saying like he is
who he is
sub-5 our marathon the connections aimed
at finishing on the sub fireman missed
his target by 30 seconds give it to him
yeah [ __ ] interesting interesting a
thoughtful intelligent person really
enjoyed talking to him but when he's
talking about these marathons like a
good Lord man like it's hard enough for
someone to do who's like you like for a
guy like you to run forty what how many
marathons forty what nobody say a lot
let's say forward [ __ ] for you to run
forty marathons in 40 days it's [ __ ]
bonkers right yeah that'd be a that'd be
a bigger training block than I've ever
done for sure that's crazy and you're a
[ __ ] world record holder you got a
goddamn stand-up comedian out there
right so what are you thinking about in
terms of the timeline uh well so if if I
go and try to get close to or right
around the the record for that it's you
know about a 40-day ish timeframe give
or take so you're really I think the
biggest hurdle or planning thing is to
find the timeline where you're gonna run
into the least amount of weather issues
because you're going across the country
so you're going over the Sierras and
you're going through the you know the
middle of the country and then all that
stuff so obviously you don't want to be
going over mountain passes in the middle
of winter which you probably don't also
want to be going through the Midwest in
the middle of the summer so some of us
can be kind of planning around around
that there's there's probably like some
good opportunities in the spring in the
fall that kind of catched that window of
moderate temps versus extremes
what's the gentleman that did it before
a pee
kasa like do you know Pete yeah yeah
there is man runs from San Francisco to
New York and record time look at that
guy's still dazed peeps
oh [ __ ] you want to hear something crazy
about Pete though so he did that and
then that wasn't enough because he I
think this was a year ago or two years
ago he went up in Alaska and went from
Alaska down to the southern tip of
Florida all by himself with just like
one of those push strollers and he
averaged like I think was like 50 miles
a day or something like that so yeah
folks if he went from Alaska to Florida
yeah yeah he did I forget what the
stroller so that's his food his foods in
the stroller
yeah he was dock bro you know it was
funny it was I I was about kind of
following him while he did it
crazies got a baby stroller with food in
it what a crazy idea
he uh he did when I was following him
like I you know he was logging all his
runs on Strava so it was hilarious to
see like these these weeks after weeks
where it's like 50 mile day 50 mile a 50
mile day like you know like 350 400 mile
weeks and stuff like that and then if
you like zoomed in on his route so you
could see like he'd be on this round
also you see him deviate a little bit
you'd assume any like all there's a
grocery store there that's why he turned
up his baby karma food where'd he keep
his money I don't know I am the baby
carbo bleed I'm trying to steal that
baby cart where'd he sleep I think he
stayed at hotels if I'm not mistaken
okay
I'd have to I'd have to look to bring
the baby card up the stairs yeah there's
crazy people either yeah there's
different kind of humans right like yeah
you have this idea of like what a person
is capable of and they see someone like
dining oh okay I've got to rethink this
people are capable of way more ya know
yeah it's it's nuts when you think about
as soon as you think you've found
limitations then also and some goes out
and does does something crazier or
bigger or better and the baby stroller
from Alaska to Florida what the [ __ ] man
um did you talk to him at all about this
idea
I haven't yet no I mean it's been are
you going to yeah reach out to him he'll
he'll be good about it I think yeah he's
a nice guy I know Pete so how many
people have done this run hey you know I
don't even know it's been it's a
documented route
so it's been done done you could
probably google it and find out and but
yeah it's it's probably it's more than
you'd think
it just really usually comes down and
actually you just and work with someone
earlier who did it walking I think I
think a maybe was a slightly different
route but it was basically the same
premise and he walked like some 20-some
miles a day or something like that and
was raising raising funds and awareness
for fight for the Forgotten - so will
maybe talk to him a bit - so um
the idea is late summer early fall
something like that yeah that's probably
ideal I think you want to try to catch
you want to get away from winter but you
also want to be done before the the
worst part of summer right with the
global warming do you factor that in
depends how fast ends up coming the
route might be shorter by the time I get
around to doing it if the coasts come in
though so sometime around this time next
year it should be completed is that the
idea
um maybe yeah my thought is it's
probably got to either be about like you
know a ten month like start point or
eighteen so I could either do it now or
I guess to be a little less than
eighteen but by finishing so I would
either maybe try to do it like this fall
or if I don't have enough in place by
then target kind of the end of winter
for 2021 and what would change what
would make you decide to do it 2021
versus 2020
uh justjust I mean I'm trying to respect
how much like planning it's going to
take and I haven't really started that
yet so I don't want to like necessarily
get to find out like okay let's say I
just put a date on the on the calendar
right away and then find out oh I need
to like and there's a lot more resources
I have to try to acquire to make this
happen and this in terms of logistics
like mostly logistics getting everything
just organized enough to because I don't
want to screw it up so there's that too
[Applause]